it's not that our next presenter needs
no introduction
what is desperately required are some
new adjectives to apply to a career that
has no precedence in a town that thinks
it seen everything actually is more like
a comet than a career and at the head of
that comet mr. Steven Spielberg
this seems a fitting moment for us to
pay our respects to the French director
Francois Truffaut
his untimely death cried out to be
rewritten to provide a happier ending
for a man whose work and influence and
film has enriched all of us I know I
share that feeling with you and with the
nominees for best achievement in
directing they are Milosh foreman for
Amadeus
Woody Allen or Broadway Danny Rose
Rolland Joffe for The Killing Fields
David Lean for a Passage to India
Robert Benton four places in the heart
and the winner is milos forman for
on-the-go
I must express my admiration for my
colleagues who are nominated tonight the
result of their work is making this
moment for me so much more thrilling I
want to thank Peter Schafer for writing
the play and the screenplay
Rob Islands for introducing me to the
play and so the ends for producing the
film I want to thank the whole company
of actors and the whole company behind
the camera namely Twyla Tharp Neville
Marriner Miroslav Fonzie cheque and
Wolfgang Mozart I have to greet my
colleagues and students at the Columbia
University film department and finally
I'm very proud because this is an
American movie on which a lot of
Czechoslovakian artists and technicians
collaborated to get this kind of
recognition from the members of Academy
for this kind of collaboration I think
it's very encouraging for more than
artistic or box of his reasons thank you
very much